Mark Musen: Hello, everyone.
This is Mark Musen from
Stanford University.
And welcome to the next
session of the BD2K Guide
to the Fundamentals
of Data Science.
It's a real pleasure to
introduce the speaker
for today, who is Michel
Dumontier from Stanford
University.
Michel is an Associate Professor
of Biomedical Informatics
at Stanford.
Before he was at
Stanford, he was
at Carleton University
in Canada and has
had a long career in
semantic technology
and is the co-chair of the W3C
Health Care and Life Sciences
interest group, where
he's had enormous impact
on the field in developing
approaches to using
semantic technology in the
biomedical applications.
The idea of ontology,
obviously, is very old
and dates way back to
the Greek philosophers,
but in the past 20 to 30
years has had enormous impact
on the field of big data.
And Michel will be
talking about that.
Michel.
Michel Dumontier: Great.
Thank you very much, Mark,
for that introduction.
Thank you also
for the organizers
to give me the
opportunity to share
my thoughts on ontologies.
And I hope that, throughout
this presentation,
if you have any questions
feel free to put them
in the chat box.
And we'll try to
address them at the end.
And so for today's
talk, I'm hoping
to tell you a little bit
about what ontologies are
and why we should,
perhaps, be using them,
a little bit about building
and reasoning over ontologies,
and then some applications
in biomedicine.
So what is an ontology?
Well, ontology stands for
logical discourse of existence.
And the real goal of ontology
is to uncover and describe
the nature and
structure of things.
It's been, as Mark
said, predominantly
the domain of philosophy.
It's a very long history in
the field of metaphysics.
And it's been associated
with prominent philosophers
such as Plato and Aristotle.
Now, in the case
in Plato, he mostly
focused on what he
called Forms, which--
they were kind of conceptual.
They could be of
any kind of thing
and not really are
necessarily tied to reality.
Whereas Aristotle focused on
an empirical kind of analysis,
where the types of
things that we see
are really as a result
of what actually exists,
what currently exists.
So ontology, the
study of ontology,
attempts to address
questions such as,
what does it mean to be?
What constitutes the
identity of an object?
And what categories can we
sort existing things into?
And as this field
has developed, I
think the principal idea is
that ontologies, particularly
when they're
communicated to others,
foster a shared understanding
of things, the nature of things,
and their structures
and relationships.
So early bio-ontologists
do include Aristotle
in fourth century
BC-- third century
BC, where he developed-- made
many contributions to the field
of ontology and also provided
for systematic taxonomy
of biology.
The classifications of
organisms were typically
by some shared properties and
used this binomial nomenclature
of that focused on
genus differentia.
And I'll talk a
little bit about that.
Galen is another, also
very famous, individual
that focused on
medical applications
and medical ontology for
the systematic description
of diseases, science,
and symptoms.
And he also used this
Aristotelean genus-differential
approach.
So what is this?
So this approach is
really key, I think,
to building good ontologies.
It's a kind of
intentional definition
where you do provide the
necessary and sufficient
conditions in the definition.
And you can see the definitions
are composed of two parts.
The first is the
genus, which serves
as the basis for
a new definition.
And basically, all
definitions that
contain this genus
component are considered
to be members of that genus.
And then the other component
is some differentia,
something that tells you a
little bit more specifically
about what differentiates
this type of thing
from any other type.
So, for instance, if you have,
say, a type like a rhombus,
you can define it
as a quadrilateral.
So the quadrilateral
part is the genus.
And of course, that would
be defined elsewhere.
But you're using it as a basis
to form your own definition
here.
And the particulars
of the rhombus
is that it has bounding sides
which all have the same length.
And so we can build on
that to define a square.
We can say a square
is a rhombus.
So it inherits the properties
that we've described above.
And it also has interior angles
which are all right angles.
When we build
ontologies in this way,
we can navigate it almost
like a binary decision tree.
You can look at the
properties and see if it fits
and continue down that
branch or perhaps go down
a different branch
based on that structure.
So, for instance, for
Aristotle's categories,
the main object type
was substance-- or one
of the more important
ones was substance.
And then you had a
differentia, which
would be, for instance,
whether the object was
material or immaterial.
If it was immaterial,
it was kind of spirit.
If it was material,
it was a kind of body.
And then you had two
other differentia,
where you would look whether
the body was inanimate,
in which case it would
be a kind of mineral.
And if it was animate,
it would be living.
And similarly, for living,
you would look-- is it
sensitive or insensitive?
And if it was sensitive,
it was an animal.
And then, from an
animal, you look
at whether it was
rational or irrational.
And that would
lead you eventually
to the category of
human-- and then
from which individuals
that exist in the world
would instantiate this
category and would
basically-- we would
infer that humans
were rational, sensitive,
animate and material
substances.
Biologists have a long history
of trying to do classification.
And of course, this
example is no better known
than in biological
taxonomy, where
we have different
kinds of categories
to describe the different
living organisms that we
see in the world today.
One of the three main kingdoms
is animals, for instance.
And these are divided into
phylum, into classes, orders,
families, genus, and species.
While there are
other different kinds
of ranks for the classification,
these are the main ones.
And you can see that, at
least in this diagram, how
it is simply articulated,
the differentia,
to go from the parent categories
into more specific categories.
So, for instance,
for animals, there
are organisms that are
able to move on their own.
Chordates are animals
with a backbone.
Mammals are chordates with
fur or hair and no clans,
and so on, all the way
up to Homo sapiens.
So this basically instantiates
a kind of taxonomy
where we have a
hierarchy of inheritance,
where you have an
"is a" relationship,
that every instance
of a chordate
is also an instance of
an animal, and so on.
So you can really
see this structure,
this taxonomic structure,
where you have an "is a"
relationship that holds
between one set of objects
and another set of objects.
And so you can see on the
right-hand side, this kind
of illustration that
the entities that
are considered to
be mammals are also
considered to be chordates.
The chordates are not only--
don't only necessarily contain
mammals, but could contain
other kinds of species.
And similar with
animals, animals--
chordates are kinds of animals.
But then there could also be
other kinds of animals present.
So moving from this early
understanding or development
of ontology, there's been
this increasing trend to,
I guess, in some sense,
operationalize ontology
to make it-- to apply it
into computational contexts.
And this has been, as
Mark said, an evolution
over the past 30, 40, 50 years,
where people have been thinking
a little bit more
about what does it
mean to apply these kinds of
categorical systems to things,
and how do we use them?
So Tom Gruber is also a
very important individual
in this context.
He was one of the developers
or inventors of the Siri
application, which you
can use on the iPhone.
And he put forward
that an ontology
was an explicit specification
of a conceptualization.
So let's break that down.
So conceptualization
is the way that we
think about a domain,
something that we
can articulate to others.
And a specification is some
way of writing that down.
Borst, in '97, extended this
to say, so let's focus on that.
And let's say, a formal
specification-- and again,
formal in the sense that you
have a formal language which
you can use to describe
the specification
in an unambiguous way.
And he also specified
that it should
be a shared conceptualization.
So it's not sufficient
that you just articulate it
with a formal language, but that
the definitions and meanings
that you have are shared
amongst different groups.
And then Gruber came
back a little bit later.
And again, we have a much
more pragmatic approach
to the description
of ontology, where
he says the ontology specifies
a vocabulary with which
to make assertions which may be
inputs and outputs of knowledge
agents, for instance,
a software program.
But ultimately,
that ontology must
be formulated in some
representational language.
So these kinds of requirements
are a little bit different
than what we might see for
other kinds of classification
systems.
For instance, in a
folksonomy, which
we're very accustomed to-- when
we're tagging, for instance,
images or making
adaptations of some kind,
we use some collection of terms
to enhance overall ability
to navigate through
different kinds of content.
But it's not necessarily
really formally organized.
It's mostly loosely
coupled with our intuition
about what those terms mean.
And in some cases,
people can use synonyms
for exactly the same concepts.
So there's not much
constraint here.
In contrast-- so
a glossary really
provides both the terms
and some definition
and potential explanations
or examples of use.
Controlled vocabulary
would focus more
on some enumeration of
terms that are defined so
that they can specifically
be shared and reused
and then so
communities would adopt
some particular set of terms
and ensure that these are well
understood by members
of the community
and used in a coherent manner.
And then going back to
hierarchies-- again,
are just a nested set of terms.
But the relation between one
term and another can vary.
So, for instance, in
a proper taxonomy,
you would expect to use
this "is a" relationship.
So every mammal is
a kind of animal.
But in a meronomy,
then you're really--
this relationship is a "part
of" relationship, right?
So you would have,
for instance, the arm
would be part of the body,
or something like that.
And finally a classification,
which ontologies typically are
is a set of categories in
which objects are grouped
into what you can sort,
for instance, data into,
or any other thing.
So why do we want to
develop an ontology?
Well, primarily, there are a
few different main-use cases.
The first is to provide
a formal specification
of biomedical
knowledge something
that we can represent in a way
that is relatively unambiguous,
that both people and agents can
understand and consume and use
in some way.
And one of those ways is that
they can do this classification
task by looking
at the definitions
or looking at the differentia
and trying to apply them
to, for instance, data.
We use them to develop
a common understanding
of the kinds of
entities in a given
domain and the relationships
that exist between them.
And we use them to enable
reuse of data and knowledge
in different contexts
and ultimately,
in our case, for many of
us in this community that
are listening to
this webinar, is
we try to use ontologies to
enable biomedical discovery.
So one of the most famous
or well-known ontologies
in the biomedical domain
is the gene ontology.
There are millions of
annotations on hundreds
of thousands of genes that
use the gene ontology terms.
The gene ontology
defines types that are
used to describe gene function.
And it basically has three
main categorical aspects.
The first is
molecular functions.
So what do gene products do?
The second is
cellular component,
which is where are
the gene projects--
where do they operate?
And finally, there's a
biological process branch,
which describes the
pathways and the processes
that gene products
participate in.
And so, on the
right hand side, you
can see-- this is a snapshot
from the AmiGO tool of the gene
ontology.
It has this nested
hierarchy following the "is
a" relationships, as denoted
with the [? "I." ?] And you can
see-- so from biological
process branch,
one of the subtypes is behavior.
And you can see next to it,
the numeric label indicates
the number of gene
products that have
been annotated with that label,
with that biological process.
So as you navigate
further down the tree,
there will be a narrowing of
the total number of instances
that can be applied.
But in total, there are
800,000 at least reported
on the AmiGO website.
So what's interesting
about the gene ontology is
it's-- in essence, it was
formulated to handle a problem
where many different biological
databases were crafting
their own terms to annotate
to genes and provide them with
a functional description.
And so the Gene
Ontology Consortium
came together to establish a
common vocabulary that could be
used independently of species.
And so, on the bottom chart,
you can see the distribution
of annotations across
different species,
for instance, from
human and mouse and rat.
And in that chart, it also
shows the distribution
in terms of where
those annotations have
experimental evidence or
non-experimental evidence.
So the vast majority
are somewhat
imputed from
computational means,
but human proteins and mice
proteins are very well studied.
Now, in preparation
for this talk,
I also looked up
one of the proteins
that I had worked on very
early in my career, which
was on RACA-- 1A GTPase.
And so, in UniProt-- that's
one of our protein databases--
also includes gene
ontology annotations
for protein products.
And in our work we looked
at, through mutational
or perturbations,
we looked at what
RAC1 GTPases could be doing.
And we saw that they
apparent-- they controlled
filopodia formation and
cell motility, endocytosis,
cytokinesis, and
development in slime molds.
And so these descriptions,
these functional descriptions,
are captured using
gene ontology terms.
And, as I mentioned, so
what for-- certainly,
in the case here for RAC1A,
it's basically a protein kinase
that has GTP-binding activity.
And so, if we want to see what
are all the proteins that have
GTP binding, we can do that.
And we can see there's a
wide distribution across all
the different species.
So this is the big
win for an ontology
like the gene ontology-- is to
see that no matter what kind
of biological
organism you are, you
can use the same--
the terms that
are defined in a
consistent manner
in your own biological
annotation projects.
Now, clearly, the gene
ontology on its own
is a necessary development
in the description
of gene products.
But we also need
similar terminologies
across the biological
scales to describe
the different kinds of
proteins, the different kinds
of organelles, the different
kinds of cells and tissues
and organs and organisms
all together as we
saw with the natural taxonomy.
So some disease and
phenotypes ontologies--
there are key health
care terminologies.
These are provided through
the UMLS system, where
we have terminologies
like SNOMED-CT
for clinical terminology
diseases, diagnostics,
and procedures; the
NCI Thesaurus, which
is a pretty wide-ranging
vocabulary for clinical care,
translational basic
research, public information
and administration activities;
LOINC for labs and vital signs;
and ICD-9 and 10 for disease,
epidemiology, and billing.
Other efforts have also
complemented these ones
in the Open Biomedical
Ontology Consortium,
including the disease
ontology, which
offers a standardized
ontology for human disease.
These are mapped to
these UMLS terminologies.
And it's complemented with the
human phenotype ontology that
provides phenotypic descriptions
for human hereditary and now
many other diseases.
And Mammalian Phenotype Ontology
complements the human one
by being a little bit more
broad than just human phenotypes
and encompassing-- and
had been widely used
in different kinds of
phenotyping experiments,
for instance, for
mice, rats and so on.
And finally, an
Experimental Factor Ontology
from the European
Bioinformatics Institute,
which takes in all of these
different kinds of ontologies
and tries to provide
support for discovery
in the context of many different
kinds of experimental datasets.
So we can you go
and get ontologies?
Well, Mark Musen is the
PI for the BioPortal.
It currently contains
517 biomedical ontologies
and over 7.8 million classes.
So it's obviously an enormous
number of ontologies.
It's a great resource for
biomedical researchers.
It allows you to search
these UMLS ontologies
as well the opened by medical
technologies and many more.
There are other repositories
of ontologies and vocabularies.
One of these is the linked
open vocabularies effort.
This is really largely
focused around ontologies
and terminologies to describe
data using semantic web
standards, for instance, a
research description framework,
but are widely used
outside of that as well.
All right, so what
I'd like to do now
is just give you a quick
introduction, I guess,
to more of the idea
of how do we formalize
our conceptualizations,
how do we
build computable ontologies
and reason with them,
and then follow up
with applications.
So this-- again, this idea of
formalization is the process
by which we map our
conceptualization--
so what are the kinds
of entities that exist
in the domain; what
are the relationships
and their attributes?--
into some kind of logical
representation.
And we can kind of see that
our logical representations are
essentially a set
of building blocks
in which we can
combine them to create
machine-understandable
expression that have
an unambiguous interpretation.
And therefore, we
can automatically
reason about them.
So again, the idea is
that we have concepts
that we can reuse in
different contexts
and create new expressions.
So, for instance,
description logics
is one of these languages that
we can use to build ontologies.
And we can define
something, for instance,
like a transcription factor as
being a kind of protein that
binds to DNA molecules
and regulates
the rate of transcription.
So this is an
expression that we can
describe in description logics.
And therefore, we can ask
questions about things
that bind to DNA or
things that regulate
the rate of transcription.
And we would discover that
transcription factors satisfy
these.
So one of the
languages that we have
available to build
ontologies is the OWL,
which stands for the
Web Ontology Language.
It is a product of the
Worldwide Web Consortium
and has gone through a couple
of different iterations now.
And it's the de facto
standard for building computer
ontologies on the semantic web.
There are many other languages
that are available, of course,
with all kinds of
interesting properties
and which may be better suited
for particular projects.
But this is the one
that I'll focus on here.
So one of the challenges of,
again, this formalization
process is now you really
have to think about what
you are saying to a machine.
Now it matters how
you describe something
because the interpretation
may be erroneous to us
if we don't correctly capture
it in the first place.
So OWL specifies a
vocabulary and a grammar
to express more precisely what
we mean when we are describing
entities of interest.
It provides us with the
ability to articulate
different kinds of things
or classes, the relations
or properties, and to describe
even data so individuals
and their specific values.
So different kinds of aspects
of the language, briefly--
disjointness, where
we want to know
whether things are the same
or different from one another.
We can quantify
our relationships.
So we can say, for
instance, that if we wanted
to define the class
of parents, we
would expect that a parent
would have at least one child.
And so we have this range
that we can quantify over
some relationship.
We have vocabulary
for negation, where
we can say something is-- it's
not the case, or, for instance,
that we can say that
penguins are kinds of birds,
but they do not
fly, for instance.
We also have aspects that
relate to disjunction,
so basically the
ability to express
a union, and a variety
of different property
characteristics for
automated reasoning,
so, for instance,
for transitivity,
for inferring
functional properties
or inverse functional properties
and symmetric properties,
and so on.
And there's a few
other aspects that
are-- like complex cause
expressions and property
chains-- that are very useful
but are probably more seldomly
used.
So what do we get with
reasoning over OWL ontologies?
Well, there's a number
of different properties
of-- a number of different
aspects that we can use.
The first is
consistency, where we
can determine whether
an ontology contains
contradictions.
There is
satisfiability, where we
can determine whether
classes can have instances
or whether they are logically
basically unsatisfiable,
that no instances could ever
fulfill the description that's
provided because it's
logically inconsistent.
We can compute subsumption,
where we're asking,
are instances of one class also
instances of another class?
Do they satisfy those
minimal requirements?
We can perform classification,
where we repeatedly
apply subsumption to discover
links between name classes.
And finally, we can
perform realization,
where, if we have individuals
in our knowledge base,
we can see if they are
members of classes that
are defined in the ontology.
So we can use
tools like Protege,
which is also developed by Mark,
to construct our ontologies.
It implements the OWL standard.
And it's extensible.
People have been
writing plugins.
So there's a wonderful
software framework
to build on and
exploit ontologies
that are being built.
I show a screenshot
on the lower-hand side
where, again, I designed a
quick and dirty ontology just
to describe that proteins have
amino acids as their part.
And they're are also
types of molecules.
So this can be done very
quickly, very readily.
There are also other
products on the market
to build ontologies,
including, for instance,
TopBraid Composer, which offers
this graphical interface.
But they both share
this very common view
where you have this tree-like
view of the different classes
and a description of their
properties, the attributes.
Right, so just a quick focus
here on the Protege Editor.
You can see this is the layout.
So we have, on the upper
left-hand side, the class
hierarchy organic molecule.
And we have proteins that
are types, sub-classes
of organic molecules and amino
acids that are also sub-classes
of organic molecules.
And in the lower left panel,
you can see a property
that we have defined,
which is the "has" part.
And so this-- now we
have our terminology
and our domain, which is the
different kinds of objects
that we're interested in--
organic molecules, proteins,
amino acids-- and
a relation to help
relate these two-- any of
the two or more entities
of interest, which
is "has" part.
So in the lower
right-hand side, you
can craft these
logical expressions
to describe the
relationships that
exist between these entities.
So, for instance, now, we're
focused on the protein entity.
We have two sub-class axioms.
The first is that-- so we
have that every protein
is a kind of organic molecule.
And so that forms the
genus of our definition.
And then secondly, that
proteins are comprised-- or have
amino acids "as part." so
that's our differentia.
And so the Protege editor offers
this auto-complete service
that helps you craft these OWL--
these syntactically correct OWL
expressions.
So, again, this is easy
enough for everybody
to do to go to the Protege
website, to download the tool,
to start playing around with
ontologies and reasonings.
One of the ontologies
that we have built
is the Semantic Science
Integrated Ontology, or SSIO.
And it counters many of the
different basic kinds of things
in the domain and
divides up the world
into three aspects, objects, and
processes and their attributes.
And then we can create even
more sophisticated expressions
for each of the basic biomedical
data types of interest.
So here I show you
a hierarchy that
relates to-- it goes all
the way down to a protein.
And there are other
ontologies out there
that provide
descriptions of proteins
and other kinds of biomolecules.
But suffice it to say
that, because we have also
added these axioms
into the ontology,
we can ask questions
that are not just
about to retrieve the label,
like, use the labels of things
to retrieve the types
of things of interest.
But we can actually
use the axiom.
We can ask whether or
not, for instance, what
are all the things that have
amino acid residues as a part?
And we get protein,
of course, as one
of our answers, polypeptides,
enzymes, antibodies, protein
complexes.
And amino acid residues are
themselves, by definition,
are holding themselves.
So you also see another term
there, which is all-nothing.
And the Protege
Editor, by default,
shows you that the sum
of all things is nothing.
So it's just an artifact
of the language.
OK, so in the last
bit, what I hope to do
is talk to you about a
couple different applications
in biomedicine to give you a
sense of what we and others are
doing in this domain.
And by no means is
this comprehensive.
There is a vast body of work.
And hopefully you'll see more
of it in the seminar series.
But here's a few
different applications
that I want to bring
to your attention.
So SNOMED-CT is one of
these ontologies that are
used in the health-care domain.
It's used across many
different countries
and by many providers
in the United States.
It provides common vocabulary
for recording clinical data.
And it's comprised of
about 324,000 classes.
So it's a huge ontology.
And on the right-hand
side, you can
see a sort of snapshot
of part of SNOMED-CT
towards the upper
[? lateral. ?] So there
are body structures,
clinical findings, organisms,
pharmaceuticals,
procedures, and so on.
Lots of different
things in there.
Now, SNOMED-CT uses a
pattern-based knowledge
capture.
So they really want
to express again
the features of each of the
categories that you see there.
But you can see the expression
is very difficult to parse.
You have to pretty much
be trained in this.
But the idea is that, once
you adopt a kind of pattern
for defining your genus
or your differentia,
then you can actually
automatically construct
and validate the ontology.
So we'll show you
an example here,
where Kaiser Permanente had done
some work to extend SNOMED-CT
to express some different
kinds of categories,
in particular, non-viral
pneumonia, in which, again,
here, this term contains an
element of negation-- you're
looking for things that are
not viral-- and infectious
pneumonia, which would be
caused by a virus or bacterium--
so here you have a disjunctive
clause-- and double pneumonia,
which occurs in two ones.
So you're using this
cardinality description.
In an implementation of
this, called SNOMED-OWL,
you can express these
kinds of definitions.
And when you use an
automated reasoner, what's
interesting is that it failed
to find some of the expected
subsumptions, for instance,
that bacterial pneumonia
is a kind of
non-viral pneumonia.
And part of the reason
is that the ontology
was under-constrained.
It didn't know, the ontology--
we didn't provide the reason
or information that virus
and bacterium are not
the same things,
which are required
to make the entailment.
But adding disjointness
in these concepts
led to other results from the
reasoner, and, for instance,
that one of the classes
that became inconsistent
is this percutaneous
embolisation hepatic artery
using fluoroscopy guidance.
And the cause of
this inconsistency,
which you can learn by asking
the reasoner to provide you
with some justification
for the inconsistency,
is that there is a problem in
the description of groin, which
was asserted to be a sub-class
of both an abdomen and the leg.
And these were-- these are
disjoint in the ontology.
And so this results
in the total,
like, a huge amount of
inconsistency in the ontology.
So the nice thing
about using a language
like OWL-- a formal language,
along with the reasoner--
is that when you--
again, when you're
making these kinds of
statements, when you're
providing the
descriptions that at least
provide necessary conditions
if not sufficient conditions,
it can find those expressions
that are contradictory
to one another.
Another increasingly-- I mean,
just like we saw with the gene
ontology, where we were using
an ontology for annotation
of genes, we also
use, for instance,
phenotype ontologies to do
deep clinical phenotyping
of patients.
So here, this is one
tool called Phenotips,
which uses the human
phenotype ontology
to provide descriptions
of-- on human patients.
And so it provides you
the ability to navigate,
basically-- an easier navigation
of the ontology itself,
but the ability to say that, for
instance, a patient has or does
not have a specific signs or
symptoms of some disorder,
and provides a
computable representation
of this description.
This kind of information,
this deep clinical phenotyping
using ontologies, can be used
to match patients together.
So PhenomeCentral is one
of these tools-- portals
that can be used
to find patients
that match the one
that you're looking at
or that you characterized.
So you'll have a set of
phenotypes for your patient.
And through measures
of semantic similarity,
you're going to try
to find patients
that are most like this one.
And in this tool, because
it's focused on rare diseases,
the idea is to find
other patients that share
similar phenotypes
and potentially
share the same disease etiology.
And so there's the
opportunity to communicate
with other providers that know
something about these patients.
Another application here of
using phenotypic ontologies
or disease ontologies is to
pinpoint-- more accurately
pinpoint the genetic
basis for disorders.
So in this work here
for Phenix, where,
once you collect genomic
information about the patient,
coupled with this deep,
clinical phenotyping
and modeling it, or looking at
the different disorders that
have been described
in, for instance,
the Orphanet or
OMIM or ClinVar, it
becomes possible to prioritize
the set of genes that come up
from some variant
analysis, coupled
with the phenotypic profile
to identify the genes that
are most likely to be
responsible for eliciting
the phenotypes that we observe.
So this has been applied and has
helped to identify individuals
with fairly rare disorders
that occur very infrequently.
But the fact that we
have these descriptions
allow us to identify
candidate genes.
All right, so finally,
what I want to do
is just tell you about
another-- some of the work
that we have been
doing, where we use
ontologies for drug discovery.
So one of the
projects that we did
was to identify human drug
targets using the phenotypes
from knockout mice models
and basically the side
effects of known drugs.
And so the main idea
here is that if we
can compare the phenotypes
of knockout mouse models
with the effects of drugs,
that when they are similar,
it would suggest
that the drug might
be an inhibitor of that
gene which produces
that phenotypic profile.
So to do this kind
of experiment,
though, the problem is that
drugs and their effects
are expressed using MEDRA
or UMLS terminology.
This is from one of the
databases called SIGIR, which
basically does text mining
using ontologies over products
structure or product labels.
And we also have phenotypes
from the [INAUDIBLE] genome
database, which are
expressed using the Mammalian
phenotype ontology.
So we basically have now
the problem that we have,
like, apples and oranges.
On the one hand, we have
a million phenotypes.
And then, on the other
hand, we have drug effects.
But they're not using
the same vocabulary.
So it's hard to
do the comparison
between, for instance,
a "drug side effect"
profile and a mouse
model phenotypic profile.
So what we have to
do at that point
is create mappings
or a correspondence
between the different
terminologies.
And this is really what
mappings are used for
to establish a
correspondence between one
term and another term from
different vocabularies.
And so this allows us
to have a common-- when
we can map one set
of terms to another,
it allows us then to compare
apples with apples again.
And so we use measures of what
we call semantic similarity
to compare a list of, for
instance, drug effects
with a list of mice
model phenotypes.
And then we can, looking
at their-- the intersection
over their union, we
can assign a score
that says just how similar those
profiles are to one another.
So when we do that,
when we compute
the similarity between
drugs and their effects
and mice models and their
phenotypes, what we find
is that we can, in fact,
recover drug targets in this way
pretty accurately-- in a way
that's fairly surprising.
That phenotypic
information, information
about the effects of
knocking out genes in mice,
often look like the effects
that we see in drugs
as well that target those genes.
So when we do our comparison
against DrugBank database
of known drug targets,
we get ROC AUC of 0.72.
And when we look for human
targets in another database
called Stitch, which
is both manually
curated and automatically
derived from drug targets,
we do slightly better.
And we do the best
for when we're trying
to identify mice targets.
But our success varies
depending on the receptor
type or the target type.
So one of the interesting
findings is that we can,
by doing this, we
can also pinpoint
multiple physiological
targets of these drugs.
So for instance for
diclofenac, which
is a non-steroidal
agent-- it's used
to treat pain, osteoarthritis,
and rheumatoid arthritis-- what
we find is that 46% of
the effects of the drug
can be explained by COX-2
knockout, which has features
like inflammation, gastritis,
constipation, upper GI tract
pain.
And the other roughly 50% can
be explained by a knockout
to PPARg.
And this regulates metabolism,
proliferation, inflammation,
and differentiation.
So these genes, when
they're knocked out,
they give you-- and
this is the whole basis
for a lot of biology,
which is this perturbation
to uncover gene
function-- they tell you
what roles that they're
participating in.
And we can see that in terms
of when the drugs are also
inhibiting those genes.
OK, so, in summary, I know
that this was a quick run
through ontology.
Obviously, there is much,
much more to ontology.
But I think, here, the hope
is to describe to you in a way
that hopefully, you get some
sense of the different tensions
that we have in building
ontologies by considering
the many contributions of
the field of philosophy,
of metaphysics, to understanding
the world and the kinds
of things that exist and
how what relationships
hold between them.
There are many formal
theories of ontology
that we try to
implement in practice,
using formal languages
like OWL and others.
And primarily, OWL, again, is
one of our de facto languages.
It's extremely powerful.
But it's also very
easy to go wrong.
And so when you're building
the ontology, nothing--
the only way that you
can find that you made
an error is if your ontologies
were sufficiently expressive.
You've made an
attempt to, again,
formalize these differentia
between the different classes.
And then the reasoner will
do a lot of hard work for you
to try to find inconsistencies
in those descriptions.
What I hope I've
convinced you is
that ontologies have a wide
variety of biomedical uses,
from basic answering
of questions--
this is one of big motivations
from, again, the shared
understanding of
these different terms,
that if you ask questions you
get answers for them in the way
that you expected them.
But then also that
they have a role
to play in data integration
and in a variety
of biomedical knowledge
discovery settings.
OK, so I want to acknowledge
a number of individuals
I have shamelessly stolen and
adapted slides from, leaders
in the field, including Mark
Musen, who is here at Stanford;
Barry Smith, who's at the
University of Buffalo,
a preeminent philosopher in the
field of biomedical ontology,
in particular; Ian Horrocks, one
of the architects for the web
ontology language; Robert
Hoehndorf, a collaborator
of mine, where we do
this drug discovery work
using ontologies;
Melissa Haendel, who
is working on integration of
genotype-phenotype descriptions
across species in her
monarch initiative;
and Paul Scofield, who
has also been contributing
to that and many other things.
All right, and with that,
I'd like to thank you
for your attention.
And I'm happy to
take any questions.
Mark Musen: Thanks, Michel,
that was fantastic.
Again, everyone
who has questions
should type their
questions into the chat.
With this many
people on the call,
if you would unmute everyone,
the background noise
would be terrible.
So please put your
questions in the chat box.
And we'll try to
get them in order.
While people are typing, let
me ask you a question, Michel.
One of the tensions that we
feel in the big data community
is a question about whether
ontologies are even worth it.
That means there's
this undercurrent
that ontologies are large.
They're hard to build.
They're hard to maintain.
Can't we just learn
all of the distinctions
that we need from data?
And is it possible that
the advent of the big data
revolution will make
ontologies less important?
I'm curious what thoughts
you might have about that.
Michel Dumontier: Yeah, that's a really
good question, Mark.
There have been-- there are
increasing numbers of attempts
to build data-driven ontology.
Trey Ideker published a paper, I
think, a couple years ago now--
I think it was called "Nexo"--
where he was trying to learn
the cellular compartments, or
basically the part of the gene
ontology dealing with cellular
components from interaction
data.
So in some sense, some
of the relationships
that we see in ontologies,
the things that we know,
and the relations
that hold to them
should be evidenced in the
data that we are collecting.
The problem is, of course, that
what we often use ontologies
for is this communication
between individuals
about the terms that they
use and what they mean.
And you know, frankly, science
is constantly changing, right?
Our understanding of the
basic kinds of things
and what they do
is always changing.
Annotations of
proteins, for instance,
functional descriptions of
proteins are being added
and also retracted.
And they need to be
evidenced by experiments.
And it seems to
me that the value
of having, again, a
consistent set of terms
to use for annotation--
which fundamentally enables
the kinds of
computations that we do--
I don't think the people
who only, for instance,
use text-mined, compound
nouns or anything like that
would be able to find
the same kinds of things
that we do when we have
these structured annotations.
Text mining itself
is hugely enhanced
by having terminologies to use.
And that includes capturing all
the different kinds of synonyms
in various languages.
So it seems like we
will always need,
at least for the foreseeable
future, an involvement
of humans to ensure the
accuracy of the kinds of things
that we're interested
in, and particularly
to provide this
query-answering capability.
Of course, I'm
shown to be, like--
even that is being challenged
by systems like Watson that
are capable of
learning associations
between different terms and
to answer simple questions
or questions like on the
Jeopardy challenge that we saw.
But even Watson uses
structured terminologies.
So it seems like-- it's
some combination thereof.
And I think those are going to
be the most successful projects
are going to think a little bit
about how far we go with data?
And then, do we need some
extra input from humans
because the data just
isn't sufficient to do
a task that we're looking for?
You raise an interesting
issue, Michel.
And that is, science changes.
And suddenly you learn that
you have reverse transcriptase
and you make DNA from RNA.
Or sometimes you find out that
Pluto is no longer a planet.
Given the fact that
the world changes,
how you know whether your
ontologies are actually
still valid?
You mentioned that SNOMED
has more than 300,000 terms.
How do you know
where the bugs are?
Yeah, that's, I think, where
ontology meets some software
engineering, right?
I think we see--
we're increasingly
seeing-- and we use this in
our own ontology development--
these patterns where we can
instantiate class descriptions
in some regular way.
And by doing that,
we know that we
can check the consistency of the
knowledge that we're authoring.
And I think that scales
to really big ontologies.
It used to be, 10
years ago, enormously
challenging to reason
about a very large ontology
like SNOMED.
And today, you can do it
in extremely short periods
of time.
It's entirely feasible to do.
The problem, I think,
the bigger problem
is the fact that we have
500 ontologies, right?
There's so many to choose from.
They are partially overlapping.
They are also possibly complete
with the domain because
of the changes, right,
or our understanding.
And so if you start
using one ontology
and another one comes in that is
potentially applicable for you,
how do you make sense of that?
How do you use
multiple ontologies
and not confuse everybody about
what it is that you're doing
or how to use this in
some computational way?
So I think this is one of
the next great challenges--
is making sense of the 500-plus
ontologies in BioPortal
in a way that users that are
trying to do their task, which,
let's say, is
annotation or analysis
are pretty much, like,
they don't need to worry
about all this other stuff.
But getting to that
point, I think,
is-- still poses a significant
challenge for all of us.
Mark Musen: I agree.
A questioner is asking, "How
do developers of ontologies
get feedback from the
communities that use them?
And there any other-- any
kinds of standards or tools
that can facilitate
that kind of feedback?"
My understanding is-- so
if you go to BioPortal,
for instance, is that
you'll see metadata
about the ontologies,
which includes-- often
includes the home
page for the ontology.
But more and more of these
ontology-based efforts
have some kind of mailing list
or discussion forum as well
as issue trackers.
This is, some of these
things are, for instance,
foundational principles in
the Open Biomedical Ontology
community.
People can make
suggestions for new terms.
They can suggest
revisions, and so on.
However, again,
there is no guarantee
that your terms that
you're suggesting
are going to be incorporated.
People have vigorous debates
about the definition of things.
And this certainly happens
in health care terminology
setting, whether it's
ICD or SNOMED or whatnot.
This pits people
against each other,
trying to figure out
what exactly are we
talking about here,
and which-- if we
do this is, is it pragmatic for
the users of these ontologies?
So that tension is always there.
But I think the biggest
thing, and something
that I'd encourage everybody,
is that when you see something
not quite working the way that
you had hoped, that, I think,
at this point, we're sort
of beyond the bonanza,
the wild west of ontology
building with so many now.
Now, it's really going to be
about refinement and hopefully,
some consolidation,
right, some ability for us
to have a coherent view
of all of these ontologies
that is maximally
useful for all users.
Mark Musen: A question points
out that there's
another ontology
language called OBOE,
and wonders how that's
different from OWL,
and why is there more than one
language to build ontologies?
Michel Dumontier: Yeah, so OBOE-- one of the early benefits of OBOE--
it's a very simple
language, again,
to capture these basic
definitions of-- so
human-readable
labels, definitions,
synonyms had been extended
to contain, again,
the ability to do this
hierarchical organization
and descriptions of the
kinds of relationships.
And some work-- I think,
maybe seven or seven years ago
or something-- was to then
map languages like OBOE
to the web ontology language.
So there is a formal,
now semantic to OBOE.
It mirrors what we see in OWL.
And so OBOE is now
a syntax that can
express the OWL axioms that you
might generate, and vice versa.
Again, from the perspective
of language development,
there are many languages.
Of course, I only
touched on one.
There are many more
expressive languages than OWL.
There are lots of
reasons to choose
a different kind of language.
But frankly, this is a
standard from the W3C.
And just like how HTML provided
a generic platform for us
to read web pages with
a single browser--
we can browse the
whole internet,
or a very large part of
the internet using that.
What we don't want
to see is languages
that don't interoperate
with one another.
So what I get the sense
of is that new languages
or new developments
are building on
these formally
defined semantics,
providing the correspondence
between different languages.
And then, in that way,
we extend our capacity
to express different
kinds of constructs.
Mark Musen: Is there a standard
ontology database
endorsed by NIH that
allows conversion
between disparate resources?
And would BioPortal
eventually be it?
Michel Dumontier: Yeah, I don't know, Mark.
Is it?
Mark Musen: I don't know.
I don't think NIH
necessarily goes
around endorsing standards.
But I think BioPortal
would probably
be it, inasmuch as it
is the resource that
contains all the publicly
available ontologies
and biomedicine [INAUDIBLE].
Other resources tend
to be more selective.
So in some sense,
I think, BioPortal
might be that resource.
But I think it's really
up to what users need
and what their
applications require.
Michel Dumontier: Yeah, I mean, there are
other ontology repositories.
The European
Bioinformatics Institute
have an ontology repository.
There is this [INAUDIBLE]
ontology repository,
the AberOWL ontology repository.
And then there's a variety
of ontology repositories
that go beyond the biomedical
scope, like the Tones one,
and so on.
So there is a smattering
of different ontology
repositories.
Many of them are drawing
from the source code.
Like repositories where
these ontologies are stored,
they offer some kind of both
archival and/or change-view
functionality.
So I think it's just a
matter of looking at them
and seeing what works for you.
Mark Musen: OK, are many people
conversant or skilled
in using multiple ontologies?
I'm not sure if that's a
question about the workforce
or a training question or what's
necessary to actually conduct
work in this area?
Is there much work to be done in
the mapping between ontologies?
Maybe those are two questions.
Michel Dumontier: OK, so the first
question pertains
to-- so is it is it common for
us to use multiple ontologies?
Sorry, Mark, is that right?
Mark Musen: Yeah.
Michel Dumontier: OK.
Mark Musen: And I guess-- are there
many people who can do it?
Michel Dumontier: Oh, I know many
people who can do it.
Mark Musen: In any case, what is the
job market for ontology?
Michel Dumontier: Well clearly, again, the
gene ontology, I think,
has provided or afforded
so much tool development,
software development.
Many bioinformatics
researchers are fundamentally
familiar with that.
We can use the gene ontology
for enrichment analysis,
all kinds of
association analysis,
all kinds of functions there.
So there's plenty of tutorials
and code and training material
as to using an ontology like
the ontology for biological data
analysis.
And similarly, I'd argue that
probably in the health care
domain, there is the
similar kinds of things
that are being done for cohort
analysis, risk analysis.
Our colleague, Nick [INAUDIBLE],
does this kind of work
on using ontologies
for processing
the notes of electronic
health care records,
and subsequently doing
analyses to look at cohorts
and their risks, the
diseases, and so on.
I think it's mostly a
matter of these use cases.
In our work, where we look
at multiple properties
of, for instance, drugs
stemming from the molecular
to epidemiological,
we're dealing
with all kinds of
terminologies, upwards
of 20 different
terminologies for one
analysis, coupled with 10 to 15
different databases, and so on.
So it becomes a
pretty big project,
but increasingly easier to do.
We offer-- for instance,
another project
that we do is called
Biotreaty [INAUDIBLE].
We have data in a
uniform representation
using semantic web standards.
You couple that
with the ontologies.
You vastly reduce
the amount of work
you have to do to
use those data.
But it's up to you to
think about the application
that you want to pursue.
Mark Musen: Great.
What tools are available
to identify ontology terms
in literature?
Michel Dumontier: Yeah, well, so I mean,
I can tout here--
so the NCPO, which Mark
leads, has an annotator tool.
So you can pick and
choose the ontologies
you want to use to do
an annotation task.
So that's very useful.
I know there's a UI
and an API component.
That's a real quick
and dirty kind
of way to start analyzing text
that match the terms that you
have in the ontology space.
Again, the challenge
is, is really
worrying about potential
false positives.
A lot of terms,
especially acronyms,
have multiple different
kinds of meanings.
They're not unambiguous.
They map to many
different things.
So I think the challenge
with-- certainly,
text-mining with ontologies
is you have to really think
about your use case.
If you're interested in a
large-scale analysis where
you're not asking a question
about any individual,
then you should be able
to find signal over noise,
even if you don't do a
great job of always being
precise with your annotations.
Now that doesn't always hold
true for some kinds of diseases
or procedures that
you're looking at.
You're using very common words.
And then it's just
practically impossible
without some other
corresponding information.
There are other tool kits.
Increasingly we see also aspects
to some kind of deep learning
over text to better extract
or-- either identify
entities or extrapolations.
Lots of work is
being done there.
But again, working with text
is extremely challenging.
And I think there's
plenty of work
left to be done to improve
the methods for good use
of ontology over text.
Mark Musen: What do you do with
a situation when
the ontology has to
categorize an entity
and it doesn't fit cleanly?
A questioner asks, what
you do with aspirin, when
in one context, it's a pain
reliever, in another context,
it's a blood thinner?
How do you answer
simple questions like,
what is this entity?
How do you classify it?
Michel Dumontier: Yeah, that's a
really good question.
It's actually one that we're
struggling with right now as we
look-- as we use-- we try
to do prediction of new drug
indications.
And a lot of these
indications are
drawn from actually text-mined
annotations, in which there
are many incorrect values.
It's a very difficult problem.
I think our approach is mostly
that you can create structures
or knowledge structures
that capture,
for instance, a context in which
some function or functionality
is being executed.
So again, if you want to
articulate that aspirin
can act as a potential blood
thinner in some circumstance,
then you really need the
ontology, or the description,
to do that.
We have developed a
tool called [? HighQ, ?]
where we have this event-based
representation, where we say,
OK, what are the
components in the event?
What are the agents that, for
instance, potentially cause
change?
And what's the
biological context?
Or what's the circumstance
under which this occurs?
And so this kind of approach
is event-based representation
is also very prominent in
other kinds of analyses,
analytical analyses, but is not
really prevalent in the way we
currently construct ontologies.
There's this modulation of
the context, whether in space
or in time or other
interactions with other systems
is not often done.
But increasingly,
I think, that work
that [INAUDIBLE],
Chris [INAUDIBLE],
Melissa Haendel, Peter
Robinson, and others are doing
are also striving to capture
this sort of information.
So it's a little
bit of provenance,
a little bit of context,
and, I think, an enhancement
of the description of these
functional circumstances that
need to happen.
So we do it in our work.
But it's not prevalent,
I think, in doing this.
Even when you look at UniProt
that captures these-- again,
these annotations of, like, I
showed you for RAC1A functions,
this kind of control only may
happen under some circumstances
and not others.
And that's not
necessarily detailed.
What they'll tell you is what's
the experimental evidence
for the annotation
that you see, but not
necessarily the full context
that you need to unambiguously
interpret or understand and
what context that's occurring.
Mark Musen: Thanks, Michel.
We've reached the
end of the hour.
The questions have
been fantastic.
We actually have
many more questions
that we didn't get to.
But unfortunately, we
don't have the time.
Let me thank you for
your presentation, which
was wonderful.
And we thank everybody
who dialed in
and everybody who will watch
the replay of your talk online.
And we'll have another
session next week.
Thanks everyone.
Michel Dumontier: Thank you.
Mark Musen: Bye-bye.
Michel Dumontier: Bye.